hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to March an indie game
that's highly rated and I know nothing
about I didn't even know if it's horror
not her anyway but I'm gonna give it a
try and I'm gonna play that I was
awful
by the way imma try not to screw up so
let's begin
ding does that mean it's about to be
good hope so ooh that's pretty
it's like some pop art poster hello am I
supposed to go towards is not a love
story okay what is it then
what is that is that a mannequin okay hi
oh hi oh hold her hand
she follows that's a she looks like a
bunch of blocks like near her look for
the two dots
you mean her eyes her rather
precariously glowing eyes oh oh oh
okay oh okay
listen and find her I'm so confused
wait what oh hi I didn't really need to
listen you were kind of right in front
of me this is come along okay come along
with me young Lee God it's uh I don't
like this uh oh why am I doing this okay
I guess this is the symbol of
togetherness and friendship even though
it's really it wasn't like this in
reality why not because it's really
weird and very polygonal huh oh that's
really pretty is that supposed to mean
something
I never led her by the hand from my
perspective she doesn't really have
hands I mean even if I stretch my
imagination a little bit we were just
together okay
I was satisfied with what we had well
what do we have
I'm being followed by a weird blocky
girl even if I forgot she was with me
still better than complications
oh I remember she's with me what is this
booth what is this supposed to mean
who's that you move faster and jump with
spacebar when unburdened okay so I can't
jump when I'm burdened by holding her
hand oh but it's very dark and the
colors go away
wait this isn't better I'd rather hold
it is that supposed to have some meaning
I'd rather hold her hand and be able to
see than jump up but maybe I need to
jump up to progress what am I supposed
to be able to remember oh maybe I'm
supposed to go here and there's gonna
bring us up she did light up my life Oh
God this is gonna be really sad isn't it
I didn't want it to be sad I was hoping
for an interesting maybe clever funny
game oh I get it okay so if we're
okay so if I leave her there I'll be
able to see her at least but what does
that mean
what does that mean what am I supposed
to do oh okay she lights up my life Oh
God who's gonna have some really sad
meaning I went him I went into this play
through all bombastically like hey we're
gonna have some fun aw crap I wonder if
she felt the same well I don't know I
kind of just abandoned her she's
lighting up my life somehow I don't know
what I'm supposed to take out of this
I'm supposed to do about this I'm
already starting to get sad I wasn't
supposed to have to feels all right
piano music it's so emotional
heart-wrenching even oh my god I feel it
and feel all the feels ah we were okay
with doing our own thing good this would
be a long way to fall really show my
skill if I fell my skill of nothingness
she and I were fine with this distance
until ding ding ding ding ding ding bing
bong bring it on
anybody wanna tussle with the muscle I
guess what's OMI supposed to be playing
right now oh hello
happening I don't know I can't I kind of
hear it it's directional getting closer
getting real close out oh that's creepy
I'm right on job ever come on kind of
disturbed come on she's got to be right
here oh come on she's like running away
from me okay she's got to be right on
top of me I don't know what I'm supposed
to be doing now I gotcha yeah
you thought you could run away from me
huh huh
that sounds really mean doesn't it huh
that's not what I meant but I mean I
could have sworn that sound was moving I
was like holding down the W chasing it
down she was going to be leaving
following her own life and ambitions
okay so good right I was fine with it
good everything seems normal so far
don't change it I wanted her to be happy
great that's good for us what's leaving
of that we simply enjoyed being together
for the time being
great all right I'm so happy that you're
happy
oh hi but by okay I played it out in my
head played what out she would leave
would we keep going on I don't think so
I wasn't going to chase her right she
knew that okay whoo yep okay if she
wanted to keep going she would have to
come
would it have convinced me these jumps
are getting a little more complicated
now but I got it with him all my fame
and vigor and skill I didn't want to
stop her from finding someone else okay
yeah I was mature about it okay
this is all a lot of exposition but it
seems to be leading up to something that
says no big deal nothing dramatic okay
that's what somebody who's not coming
with it okay would say yeah for now we
had each other whoa
all right whoa hello
Thanks I think I followed you here I'm
not sure God when you turn when you snap
turn to me like that it no good it's
make me startled ooh god this is so
crazy lady ding-dong whoa what is that
it's a countdown but why I don't seem
good what is do what is why do doesn't
make long distance we are that close
long distance long distance I can move
faster it seems like some kind of smash
poetry in motion going up break it off
she doesn't need me she'll be an
obstacle she doesn't need me god this is
so sad what is going on I can move
faster without her I can move fast oh
okay it's asking me even if she comes
back she'll leave me again clean break
clean break long distance oh so I guess
I like have a choice oh I'm not gonna
make it aah Oh No
Oh Oh I would have made it if I wasn't
holding her hand that's got to show some
meaning right there in the end of course
we stayed together I knew I was in love
I had no doubts
I wouldn't toss her aside but that isn't
what happened we will see the story to
the end we will tell the story right oh
ah you're making me do the thing oh you
make me do it I'm faster without if
that's what the countdown was I didn't
see the thing dropping in the distance
ah it's so sad well here we go I guess
marching along to the end of a
relationship is so sad
typhus brings up a lot of bad memories
for people I've had bed you know
breakups in the past and like really
rough and it's just like you can only
hope that people move on and be friends
afterwards I mean even though that's a
cliche but hey I'm really sorry if this
brings up bad memories just know that
you know things don't all we always have
to be bitter and angry afterwards just
like people can be human and still move
on with their lives even if it doesn't
work out I guess safe from heartache
safe from us but mostly from myself God
is so ah I'm so sorry
much later how much later she came back
to finish other things I speak really
slowly I speak softly and carry a big
stick
I saw her but we were different I was
different okay
that's good are you telling me are you
just telling yourself that huh Oh skill
yeah skill words that will cling to our
hearts unspoken
I hope I don't fall because this would
really suck this seems like a long way
to go her avoiding eyes okay what does
this mean why is it all mean it's gonna
end tragically talking to each other
about nothing alrighty then that's good
I guess uh the fourth smile and laugh of
my regret what ah ah hello okay goodbye
that mean some I can't move my mouse oh
I did why I get into the feels
I wish your happiness and I'm sorry see
you later then what what is that the end
of the game
why huh you're gonna end it on that
you're a nd like that what I don't even
understand why oh that didn't even seem
like some sort of conclusion why ha ha
little goose now huh what the hell ah
all I did was open up a can of worms to
make everyone in the audience feel bad
I'm so sorry everybody
oh yeah either way I guess that's Yin so
oh man I guess I guess in a way it's an
important message like it like some of
these games aren't exactly fun in terms
of game but if you want to look at
gaming as art this is what this would
represent this is gaming that expresses
someone's feelings towards their
relationship their relationship or
someone that broke off early on and they
never held on tightly because they
always thought that they wanted distance
and there's some message in there that
you like if you want something hold on
but also at the same time that's not
always right
like it's not always the best option so
it's
open to interpretation whether it was a
good option as a bad option to you hold
on to someone like clinging for dear
life or to let them go and do their
thing like it it's a different situation
for everybody like you can't be
determined in some fashion this is just
one person's perspective on their story
and then it was just at the end of that
they went off and he was she was happy
with someone else and he wished them
happiness I guess I didn't expect that
to be that I was creeped out in the
beginning users what the hell happened
was with these games that messed with my
mind and messed with the hearts of all
my fans I'm sorry everybody but I hope
you enjoyed it on the lesson I hope you
got something out of it please let me
know in the comments what you think this
meant to you like you what you think
this meant because this means something
but it's open to interpretation what it
means or it's not maybe it's not open to
interpretation maybe the developer knew
exactly what it was supposed to be I
don't know let me know let me know what
you think in the comments below thanks
again everybody so much for watching
click the annotations or look in the
description for more videos that I've
done and as always I will see you in the
next video bye bye
there's so many people here then
this way people that eva videos have
touched and here's a guy named Ian
another fan that destroyed me so badly
should be to buy cool but I got to be in
this cool thing called the Blitz cam
which produced this amazing video